I'm gonna be honest here a lot of people
aren't gonna like what I have to say but
friends don't lie
stranger things too
last time that I checked in with you
folks I finished the first four episodes
I have now finished the back five I've
seen all nine episodes and most of the
run time of this video is gonna be taken
up with me complaining but let me say
some things up front all right and
here's your warning spoilers because I'm
just gonna get into this it's not bad
and actually if I did not have to by its
nature compare this to stranger things
season 1 if this existed in more of a
vacuum I probably love it
unfortunately there's no way for me to
not compare it to stranger things season
1 and by that measure there's a lot that
I feel let down by that I feel
disappointed by that I feel is missing
and oh this is all stuff that I'll get
into as we go along but there is nothing
truly wrong with this season well
there's a couple specific things I'll
[ __ ] about I don't get to them and
they're not they're not huge in the big
scheme of things most of what I'm gonna
talk about him what doesn't work for me
has to do with me and kind of what I
wanted out of the season and I suppose
maybe for a bit of context is I here's a
good point of reference I think because
I've seen the or I've heard the
comparison made that in some ways this
is it's stranger things to is the aliens
to stranger things one that is alien
this is aliens so and that's not a
horrible comparison you know it the
implications are much bigger we see more
of the monsters we have a bigger version
of the monster it's much more about
grander stakes and it's not just this
personal little survival rescue kind of
story
so I like the original alien better than
I like aliens aliens is still good I
like the
better I like the smaller stories I like
the more intimate character based focus
more than you know the grander we have
to save the world thing that's not to
say I don't enjoy
let's save the world stories but as much
like my feelings on the new Blade Runner
movie I loved the intimacy of the first
one that was that was the case here so
when it when it went bigger which the
season does it it didn't lose me but you
know I was way more invested on these
key just this group of kids you know
hiding 11 and finding their friend will
then I ever was in you know oh should
they take down this government
organization oh my god what happens to
the world if these things get out like
the minute you say you know the world's
at stake my interest drops it just does
because you you you've over sold it and
I mean it's one it's it's different when
you're dealing with a story that
inherently is dealing with world ending
stakes like something like The Avengers
that's inherently the world's at stake
fine I know that going in but when you
start with smaller intimate personal
character based stakes and they go and
the worlds in danger I'm like I don't I
don't care
that doesn't up the stakes for me but I
god I've started going negative already
positive positive positive let's start
by saying some nice stuff performance is
all good all the write all of the
original cast all the returning cast
even the new characters who I don't
particularly like we'll get back to that
are still well performed for what is
written in what is expected of them
there are a lot of cool little moments
be they interactions between characters
that are unexpected odd there's a lot of
really sweet moments a lot of sweet
connections we get that with hopper and
11 we get that with Bob and
and Joyce there's there's a lot of those
kinds of things across the show
I think Dustin is particularly adorable
as much as some of his actions annoyed
me but Lucas called him out on the very
things that he did that ticked me off so
I felt slightly vindicated and it kind
of relieved the tension a little bit as
far as that went as cheesy as it was the
moment with d'Artagnan I I kind of went
with I kind of roll with it that was
nice Steve was awesome I love Steve
steve is is probably like a top four
characters in this show for me at this
point between last season and the season
love love me some Steve I really like
Paul Rizer I like that he gives a human
face to this government organization
that's obviously up to some not-so-nice
stuff but when he's in that room with
those other guys and one of them says
look if the boy dies the boy dies in
Para just looks at him go say that again
like that great moment in that and that
reaffirmed what I hoped he was as a
character which was a guy who has this
job who's it's a you know it matters
that he keeps this gate mater that they
get all the data that they're going in
but he still cares about the impact he
cares about the people that are affected
by this that's what I wanted that's what
they hinted at and I'm glad they
delivered that I'm glad he didn't
suddenly pull back like oh no I'm really
evil like thank you thank you for not
going there the visuals are all good the
the effects are still really good but
and you beyond the effects just the
imagery of this show is really really
good on a lot of levels
Elevens makeover I will love it I'm not
entirely 100 sure why but I really
really like it I don't know why it
worked as for me so there's a lot of
good points in this there's a lot of
good things in it and even the stuff
that I'm about to start complaining
about isn't necessarily awful but it's
all stuff that weighed on my enjoyment
of the thing overall the first is I'm
gonna rehash something that I said about
the first four episodes cuz it held true
pretty much throughout the season which
is this thing lacks a strong central
pillar that everything is built around
because the first season had the
appearance of will buyers everything
circled that the actions of the facility
and Elevens involvement it was still
based round she knows she knows where
willis she can help us find will the
kids involvement Joyce
hopper everything circled this one
easily graspable easily relatable
situation missing kid must find this
season doesn't really have that this
season just has a bunch of just
narrative threads that eventually come
together but in a way that feels largely
coincidental like everyone who was
involved in the season one story you
immediately got why they were there why
they were involved how they got roped
into this there's a lot of characters
involved in season two new and old that
as far as the narrative is concerned I
don't know why they're there I don't
know why max is there I like max as a
character but I don't know why she's
there really I don't know what function
she serves for the narrative I don't
know really what she brings other than
like giving Lucas somebody to Lucas and
Dustin somebody to fawn over which I
don't think was really necessary I mean
it was cute it wasn't bad but and I
don't know why she's there and connected
to that I don't know why her brother is
there I don't know what purpose what
greater purpose all of that served but
like I said it's not just new characters
i mike has nothing to do in this season
zero like he's he is so superfluous mike
is so completely secondary to everything
going on in this show that if he was not
a character in the first season if you
were just writing this store this story
and you didn't have season one ahead of
time he's not a character that you would
write he's not doing anything worth like
wolf this character didn't already exist
we'd have to invent him no you wouldn't
because he does nothing like pretty much
his only function is completely
logistical which is for him to have that
moment with max to have eleven spotter a
spot them together and then just go
which even that I know
I think was necessary because I think if
you just showed her being single mind
and focused on her mother after she had
that vision of her that would have been
enough to justify her actions sort of
thinking I'll come back for Mike after
this whole her being jealous of Max
thing is dumb and I get it I'm not
saying it's not relatable I'm not saying
I don't understand it or that it's
unjustified by the character I just I
don't like it I think it's predictable
and dumb and actually predictable might
be the word that kind of brings the
whole season down for me which is that a
big part of the first season is that I
didn't know what the rules were what
that sort of the the narrative and the
genre tropes that the show was working
in so I spent pretty much the whole the
first season going okay okay well how's
this work how's that work
you know our characters safe who could
die I'm getting everything established
I'm getting a feel for the rules coming
into season two pretty much everything
played out how I would have expected
them to play out based on the rules of
this narrative universe that I came to
understood understand from the first
season I mean everything makes sense
none of it's none of it's bad and I mean
none of it is illogical but not nothing
surprised me about this season almost
nothing caught me off guard and even
stuff that was probably supposed to like
when Bob died like I like I called that
I called that in advance and then I
literally I counted down to it I called
it to the second so I knew once he
volunteered to go down and fix the
breakers I'm like oh god he's mr. Arnold
in Jurassic Park but I mean just
functionally he is fulfilling it very
tried and true role oh he's the guy
who's going to make it possible for
everyone else to escape but once he's
done that there's no need for him
anymore so he dies that's always what
happens is what happened with Jurassic
Park it's what happened with forgetting
Michael Rapaport Erik tur in deep Lucie
it's a very tried and true trope so when
he was trying to run away he gets
through the door he shuts the door
behind him and one of
demo dogs I'll come back to them one of
the demo dogs like slams on the door and
he gets it he's in the lobby and he sees
Joyce and the camera slows down a little
I literally counted it down it's like
and boom and right when I said it hit
the hip from with one of the dogs from
the side and he was down like to the
second
I called that and again it's not that
it's bad it's that it was really really
predictable and you know in the scope of
maybe you know the tropes of sort of
eighties feeling sci-fi horror enos
maybe some of these ideas were fresh but
they feel very much in line with
everything that was set up in the first
season it all just feels like yeah okay
that's yeah that's that is the thing
that makes the most obvious sense to go
from there I do a I mentioned the demo
dogs I wanna I think it was a boring
decision to basically just do the demo
gorgon again but smaller and more of
them I mean that's that's what the
tremors franchise did come on stranger
things you're better than that
and it made it made the the world of the
upside-down seems smaller because now
the shadow monster that was a good call
that was a good scaling up it had a look
that was consistent with the world of
the upside-down but it wasn't just a big
demagogue and it was a whole other thing
but the devil dogs like they got that
same head that the demagoguery had so
it's just so what everything that is
alive in this universe just has that
head okay that's boring like I would
have been way more interested if it was
a completely different design on these
things and I mean it was good for one
singular moment which was you know
showing the reveal and then you know it
made it clear to Dustin more or less
well where this thing came from and what
it was about so I I kind of get it but
it just makes the upside down feel
smaller makes you feel more limited it's
no longer this this you know vast just
expansive wasteland with who knows
what's there now it's like oh it's a
bunch of things with heads that go like
that and this one giant
Oh monster all right at least that's
what it feels like it didn't really feel
like they made the the upside-down
bigger it feels like in a way it now
feels more limited than it did in the
first season and now this this last
thing that are probably not lasting but
this next thing I know that I am in the
minority on this and while I haven't
sought out other people's full reviews
and I've made a point of not I'm really
absorbing everything there's one thing
that I know that I got that I that I
found right off seems to be a pretty
much universal agreement
nobody likes episode 7 but guess who has
two thumbs and likes episode 7 this guy
I like so 7 a lot it's not my favorite
episode of the season I'm not gonna go
that far but you know what there were a
lot of things I liked about that episode
now before I get into it I will say the
primary complaint so far as I could tell
without like diving into reviews like I
said I was avoiding those the primary
complaint seem to be people felt it
broke up the flow of the season and I
get that I can't really argue against
that I suppose what I can say is it
didn't bother me because the
cliffhangers weren't really grabbing me
the only one that did to see the the
episode three cliffhanger where the the
shadow monster just kind of pours into
wills like that okay like I'm like I
don't know what's going on right there
and that was one of the that was one of
the few moments of the show that really
did surprise me but it's like I don't
know what's going on there I don't know
what's gonna happen next that that was
one of the few times were like I didn't
just go to the next episode because I'm
like how many more can I get in so I can
try and finish the season off I was like
III had only planned to do the first
three episodes I was planning to go to
bed then I saw that my oh I need to see
what's thanks but that was the only time
that really happened for me so the
cliffhanger ahead of episode 7 you know
is the the demo dogs coming out of the
hole I'm like well I knew that we're
gonna come out of that hole I always
knew that they were gonna come out and
over on the facility because that's just
that's what always happens so dud
was gonna happen so there I wasn't I
wasn't on the edge of my seat oh my god
what happens next cuz that point in the
story I'm like bull of course we're here
we are I knew we were gonna get here so
I was totally okay with a divergence
from that now again Episode seven is no
great piece of work I actually think
there's a lot of aspects of it that are
really goofy I mean how much how much
product is in that guy's hair than one I
just want one time when there's a
character with that spiky a mohawk I
want to see what they look like first
thing in the morning before they put
anything into it it's just good it's
just this mess on their head just one
time I want to see that but I kind of
like the dynamics of the characters I
really liked the this new character um
oh god I forgot her name again but but
she had the tattoo she and an 11 or J
know I'll still call her 11 you know
referred to her as sister I found her
interesting found her backstory
interesting I liked that she had a
different skill then 11 had I found and
and I kind of called that 11 was going
to chicken out of you know the killing
these people once that was established
what they were doing cuz initially I
thought maybe oh well they'll just
they'll start taking advantage of her
she'll go down a bad path that but
they're very upfront with her about what
what it is they do and they're like
we're gonna kill these people and 11
agreeing to that I'm like I betcha she's
gonna chicken out but the moment still
rang very true to me of her seeing that
picture realizing the kids are there and
stopping that that other girl from from
taking this guy's life I I thought it
played all really interesting and more
to the point it felt like it was a
because it was a different setting with
different characters and taking the
story in a different direction it didn't
feel like oh this is all logical from
what I saw last season this felt like it
was establishing a new set of rules for
the world as it exists outside of
Hawkins that there is more going on and
it's bigger and it it laid also the hint
of Matthew Modine character a pop of
possibly being alive I know how feel
about that depends on the explanation
but honestly I find that to be a much
more interesting thread to pull on and
go further on then everything the shadow
monster again I'm not sure I really care
about that but
I liked episode 7 sorry I did but you
know overall my feeling of the show is
just one of disappointment it's not bad
I'm not angry it's not you know second
half of defenders or anything like that
I don't get ticked off about it but it's
just it's just it's just not as good
it's not as strong it's not as
compelling it's not as gripping it's not
as focused it's just you know these
characters who are here because they
were here last time so they're back even
if there was an an arat of reason to
keep them and they're just kind of
meandering around and then they happen
to all come together through a lot more
coincidence than happened last time and
I'm hoping that having done what is
again I think the very logical follow-up
to the first one I'm hoping that things
will go in in a more drastically
different direction in the next season
or the next two seasons because
supposedly they might shoot three and
four back-to-back I don't know what the
word was on that but I I'm not soured on
the show by any means I'm just hoping
that the next season can really you can
really shake me out of what what is
starting to feel like comfort zone you
know it's starting to remind me of a
little bit is orphan black now I I
bailed on orphan black about halfway
through season four and I think my big
issue with orphan black was that it
started with this fascinating premise
and just kept running in circles but not
moving forward anywhere in many ways
this feels like season one again only
bigger and that wasn't really what I was
hoping for because I mean you know it's
it's it's the upside down again
something is invading from the upside
down again eleven stops it again and you
know I just I just want I don't just
want the same thing again but bigger
next season I want something different
and what is that I have no idea please
surprise me I wanna I I don't want to be
able to guess where things go from here
I want to be surprised by it because
very little about the season ended up
surprising me and that that kind of
bummed me out but it's still good it is
not bad like if the if the first season
was an A this is this is a b-plus so you
know it's not it is not bad and it's
just I know the show is better than what
it gave me so yeah I think that's about
it those are my thoughts on the entirety
of stranger things season 2 what did you
think of the thing as a whole whatever
you did drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
that's available on iTunes and stitcher
I am also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast that is a presentation of
the fire water podcast network fire and
water podcast.com and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]